[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Jeremy Kyle Donald Trump surrenders
the former president will be booked at
Fulton County Jail facing charges that
he attempted to overturn the results of
the 2020 election we will go live to
Atlanta Georgia and debate whether any
of his Rivals have any chance of
stopping him chaos at the Kremlin could
vote the mercenary seek revenge for the
assassination of their top dog and
should the West fear the demise of Putin
will debate later plus my friend a run
of box office flops could cost Disney a
billion dollars critics say it's putting
virtue signaling Beyond entertainment
now they're demanding the woke remake of
Snow White is scrapped we'll find out
why
thank you
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Jeremy Kyle
a very good evening and welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored yes it's me Jeremy
Carl welcome welcome welcome now eight
Republican presidential candidates went
to battle last night the winner though
somehow was the elephant not in the room
former president Donald Trump skipped
the debate tonight he's heading to
Fulton County jail in Georgia where
he'll be arrested and will pose for a
mug shot that's set to become one of the
most iconic images in world history and
that splitting legal headache is just
one of the reasons why he's battled the
second place still matters it's a big if
if Trump drops out or drops dead one of
these people will go head to head with a
president who's visibly falling apart
and that means one of these people could
well become the leader of the Free World
is there anyone on stage who would not
support the increase of more funding to
Ukraine
let us be honest as Republicans I'm the
only person on the stage who isn't
bought and paid for so I can say this
the climate change agenda
I've had enough already tonight of a guy
who sounds like Chachi BT standing up
here to go and defund Israel you want to
okay let me address that I'm glad you
brought that up I'm going to address
each of those right now you have no
foreign policy experience now is not the
time for on-the-job training we don't
need to bring in a rookie we don't need
to bring in people without experience if
former president Trump is convicted in a
court of law would you still support him
as your party's choice
thank you
six of the eight Governor Ron DeSantis
is the only Contender who's anywhere
near Trump in the polls but ever since
he first dared to trash Trump in an
interview with a certain Mr Morgan You
Might Recall it's been done against Ron
and no prizes for guessing who's winning
that fight instead the candidate
everyone's now talking about is the man
who can't stop talking another
uncensored regular Vivek Rama Swami he's
winning over Trump's supporters and you
can see why
let's just speak the truth okay
president Trump I believe was the best
president of the 21st Century
and Chris Christie honest to God your
claim that Donald Trump is motivated by
Vengeance and grievance would be a lot
more credible if your entire campaign
were not based on Vengeance and
grievance against one man
now Trump May well have been a great
president and plenty of people would
agree with that but can he really be a
great president potentially from behind
bars and can anybody in the Republican
Party stop him from winning for more on
this I'm joined by Atlanta baseball
Rachel Kaufman Rachel uh thank you for
joining me on Piers Morgan uncensored
just to give us a flavor what is the
atmosphere like right now in Atlanta
Georgia where for the fourth time uh the
ex-president Donald Trump's about to be
facing well more charges what's it like
there
well so my understanding is that there's
people lined up outside of the jail like
there's people protesting
um Trump being forced to surrender
there's people who are there cheering on
the effort of the prosecutor in
furtherance of the prosecution of Donald
Trump and the other 18 co-defendants
um I think by by having him turn himself
in and require him to take a mug shot I
think that the Fulton County D.A is is
signaling to the world that it's
different in Georgia he's not he's not
going to get treated
um like he's you know like he's the
former president Rachel is this the
first time that Trump will have to
provide that mug shot because as I said
in the introduction that will become an
iconic image for the ages won't it
absolutely you just kind of wonder if
he's thinking about what he's going to
do how he's going to pose and even in
the moment when someone snaps a you know
a photo of you some people's instinct is
to smile I'm curious the kind of Faith
he'll make we saw what um Rudy
giuliani's face looked like he looked
very angry and bitter to be there
there was a Miss Ellis one of the other
co-defendants is smiling and look it
looks like a headshot
um you know like for an actor looking
forward it is it is extraordinary for us
in the United Kingdom I mean this is
this is the most extraordinary thing
that we will follow and follow you know
an ex-president about to be indicted for
the fourth time a man who publicly said
some weeks ago give me one more and I'll
make it to the White House again played
out in front of 300 million people and
and Rachel I just wanted some idea
because we're loving every minute of
this time scale for this afternoon when
are we expecting the Donald to sweep
into Fulton
I expect she'll be there in the next
hour I don't think that he'll go there
in the early evening I think that it'll
be between I don't know between 3 and 4
P.M Eastern Standard time but because
there's already a bond worked out he
probably won't spend that much time
there so I want to say that you know
they're saying that he's not going to
get any special treatment and in many
ways he's not he's going to feel the
full force of the law in a way that I
don't believe he's felt it with the
other three indictments um this is a
serious serious prosecution however most
people who are charged with felonies
with several felonies in Fulton County
Georgia would usually have to turn
themselves in would not have the
opportunity to have a
um a bond worked out prior to
surrendering and would have to sit in
the jail which is known for patterns of
severe severe abuse and neglect of
inmates in the jail he will not have to
sit there overnight like the average
inmate and wait for a first appearance
calendar the next day when a judge could
decide whether or not to Grant Bond no I
mean there
is a slight difference he's going to fly
in on his private jet swarmed with a
special service a secret service and
going there we've heard that some of
this jail is quite rough but you're
saying it's a it's a massive moment we
will follow it and and and Rachel thank
you so much I mean this is this is one
of those things that that we are all
fascinated about and we will bring it to
you live until thank you so much adidine
let's now bring in Donald Trump's former
spokesperson uh Erin Elmore and former
Republican 2020 presidential candidate
Joe Walsh for their take on this if I
could start with you uh Aaron um this is
it it's an extraordinary thing to ask
you right let's start with the debate
before we talk about Atlanta Georgia
this man doesn't even need to turn up
and he's going to win I mean I only want
to ask this I don't want to disrespect
anybody what does this say about
American politics I mean this country is
messed but we are watching this open
mouth open mouth
well I don't think that Donald Trump
needs to show up for debate he's proven
himself he was the president of the
United States our current president
hasn't agreed to any debates with RFK Jr
so I don't think that there's that much
dissimilarity there but why would
president Trump bother to show up for a
debate when he's the clear front-runner
by some Bulls you know 20 30 percent
there's just no need for it there's
absolutely no need he's the title fight
on that boxing card he's not going to
fight with the welterweights at the
beginning while people are filling the
seats Joe well shall you respond to that
he's the title fight on a welterweight
card it's true isn't it the other way a
plan for second that's it nothing else
no point to it
I agree with Aaron there's no point for
him to be there I'd rephrase why he's
the cult leader of a really powerful
cult and barring a jail cell or a heart
attack
Donald Trump's going to be the
Republican Party nominee one indictment
or a hundred indictments he can do no
wrong I mean no wrong to a decent chunk
of the Republican Party base you said it
barring a heart attack or a cell but we
know do we not and tell me if I'm wrong
both of you under America Lori could
become the next president and still be
in jail for God's sake is that all right
absolutely I don't think that the any of
these trials due to Due Process concerns
for any criminal defendant will occur
before the election but and by the way
for two of the four cases he would be
able to Pardon himself but I believe
that he's going to be the nominee and
there's very little we can do to stop it
I think the biggest reason why he has so
much support a large segment of this
country had a massive distrust for
politicians and they found someone in
Donald Trump who said I think this
person is speaking to me it made a
demographic of the population wake up
and realize hey there is a swamp in
Washington and there was some distrust
in the mainstream media and these people
are viciously and happily loyal to
Donald J Trump let's just talk about
that debate uh Joe if we can last night
I mean eight people uh and six I've got
this clip when asked even if Donald
Trump was convicted how many of you
would support him watch this six hands
went up former president Trump is
convicted in a court of law would you
still support him as your party's Choice
please raise your hand if you would
foreign
this side of the pond it says to me that
Donald Trump has such power over the
Republican party that nobody has the
political Mouse uh to stand up and say
be gone let's Sweep with the new brush
and start again to me uh from this side
of the pond your country of 312 million
people will pick between a man who
doesn't know his name and a man who
apparently is is is a disgrace and could
end up in jail that doesn't say a lot
globally does it Joe
I'll let my colleague answer and I do
have an answer to that as well go ahead
sorry it doesn't it doesn't it says and
the world needs to know this America is
in a hell of a lot of trouble we have
two major political parties and right
now one of our major political parties
is led by a criminal somebody who's been
indicted four times Donald Trump said
years ago I could shoot somebody in the
middle of New York City and I won't lose
any support
that's still true in fact it's even
truer now he's moved Beyond The Cult
leader for Republicans he's a martyr
he's a full-fledged martyr and Jeremy
you can't move beyond that moment that's
important and it's nothing to celebrate
six or seven you know I don't want I
don't know what Chris Christie was doing
there he kind of raised his hand too but
six or seven of eight candidates said
that they would vote to send a convicted
criminal back to the White House that is
a party Jeremy that doesn't give a damn
about the rule of law can I jump in
before you do it Aaron Aaron can I just
jump in can I just jump in I mean I have
to balance both sides and you've had
your side show but but the Democrats can
they seriously look themselves in the
mirror you look at Hunter Biden and you
look I suspect at how a lot of that has
not been talked about by the liberal
media and you question actually whether
the left or the right have anything
about them in the United States right
now
amen and I agree Jeremy look investigate
everybody if there's suspicion or
potential evidence that Hunter Biden Joe
Biden Donald Trump anybody committed
crimes then pursue it the point is we're
at the point with Trump where it's been
determined that there's credible
evidence we may get there one day with
Biden we're not there yet Aaron just to
finish this a lot of people Trump's
supporters would say it's very
imbalanced it's always about Donald
Trump they've never looked at the
Democrats your response to that the
problem is we live in a country with a
constitutional republic and if I go
through these charges and I know we
don't have time Case by case there are
so many problems and dissimilarities and
special treatment that Donald Trump is
receiving in a negative way we do not
have free speech if your name is Donald
Trump and I do believe that you're
having the political party in power and
their doj Prosecuting their biggest
political adversary so to say that as a
country that we're in trouble I think
the trouble is they're not just coming
for Donald Trump everyone else is next
we are supposed to be the freest nation
in the world and by Prosecuting Donald
Trump several people many people
millions of people think that it reeks
of political corruption and makes us
like a third world dictatorship Banana
Republic and that's very sad I always
say and and I'm very grateful for you
both being on I always sell my own show
that that we should never forget
that in the last election in 2020
whatever the criticisms 76 million of
your country men and women which is more
than live in the United Kingdom voted
for this man by the way can I tell you
both this just out on Truth social
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 p.m local time in
Atlanta Georgia which will be half past
midnight here in the UK we will of
course keep you updated throughout that
just one final question because I've got
I've sort of done this up can we imagine
what that mug shot of Donald Trump will
look like I think we've got something on
screen here my friends have we got
something up Oz oh you haven't done it
for me oh there we go uh Erin uh Joe
thank you so so much indeed for your
time on uncensored tonight very grateful
and for all of you watching as I've said
we will certainly keep you updated with
that news just in Donald Trump saying he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 p.m local
time in Atlanta right 12 30 midnight our
time next and uncensored there really is
chaos in the Kremlin reports claim that
the Wagner group is plotting revenge for
the assassination yesterday of their
leader we will ask if the world should
cheer or should they fear the demise of
dictator Putin that's coming next we're
back in three
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Prime Minister President Trump Mr
President first lady Stormy Daniels
Jordan Peterson welcome to all these
people protesting just don't get it many
of them don't isn't that slightly
patronizing
when you're going through the treatments
you have some tears God I'm such a softy
I'm not a performing monkey shut up
Brian and it's something that really
hurt me because they doubt of my words
a woman is me
a woman is somebody whose breasts hang
down to her stomach I thought the
marginalized we're supposed to have the
voice I've been a terrible liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
kiss condoms the kiss caskets will get
you coming and we'll get you going I
think it's only room for one king man
now I'm saying
[Music]
so apparently I have to tell you that
you can vote for Piers Morgan and
Spencer do it please because if we are
shot in the eye for so many people the
best TV interview category the National
Television Awards by going online to it
right now have you say National
televisionawards.com or scanning the
code on your screen now and put one over
the main man the goat needs to win and I
won't hear the end of it now let's move
on Wagner group warlord Jeff Guinea
pregosian is believed to be dead his
private jet crashed from the skies north
of Moscow last night just 60 days after
he led a failed Mutiny now of course
there's fears his mercenaries could seek
their own Revenge today Putin absurdly
sent condolences to the man he suspected
of blowing out of the sky Ukraine and
the West tend to cheer chaos in the
Kremlin but history teaches of course
the demise of strong men is usually
followed by a period of even greater
Peril Russia is a country of 26
languages 100 ethnic groups and 11 time
zones spanning half of our planet
frankly it's held together by Propaganda
about a common enemy and by force and
for the past 24 years that Force has
been Vladimir Putin now we are should
the world fear what would happen without
him it's the big question joining me
first up former Russian MP Sergey Markov
we also have security expert Professor
Anthony glees gentleman uh welcome
welcome
um can I start with you Sergey and we'd
like to include everybody tonight bear
that in mind that clip of Putin offering
his condolences uh to the Wagner warlord
um have you have you seen this ever ever
watch of this if you would my friend
please
he was a man with a complex Destiny and
he made serious mistakes in life he
achieved the results he needed both for
himself and when I asked him for the
common cause as in these last months
he was a talented person a talented
businessman
that is the most absurd insincere thing
I've ever heard in the history of my
life surely you would agree
it's just because you are lost their
connection with reality connection with
reality reality is saying that all
terrorists attack have been agonized by
Ukrainian authorities residence was
personal enemy of Evgeni precaution
because
as a symbol of strong Spirit of
Ukrainian and Nation but uh
and to control over in their uh big
battle during a few months my problem
with that Sergey Sergey my problem with
that we've spoken before and you never
you never listen my problem with that is
if you are ill are you going to listen
are you going to listen why you don't
shout why you shut me up why don't this
wonderful to say Can repeat I know you
don't understand democracy in Russia but
both people are supposed to be able to
talk my friend I'm asking you this are
you literally that indoctrinated that
you believe that a man that Putin shot
that plane down appearing until Anthony
Gleason helped me out it's the most
ludicrous thing I ever seen would you
not agree sir oh absolutely absolutely
the the British people are many things
but they're absolutely not stupid they
know a liar when they see one they know
a coward when they see one they know a
war criminal when they see one we've got
a Dowdy history of going after people
like Vladimir Putin and to watch him
smirk and think that he's pulled a fast
one will convince nobody in this country
and I think we'll convince nobody in
Europe of course he shot pregozin down
at the same time as we just heard in our
very interesting clip Putin is too
afraid to actually damn him people will
be reminded of brutus's speech with the
death of Julius Caesar comes to Berry uh
praise seasonal to bury him actually
Putin does not dare say I did it we know
he did it why pregozin went off in this
plane with his closest advisors that
remains a mystery but ever since uh the
Rebellion raised by precaution we have
known that either Putin was a dead man
walking or pregozian was a dead man
walking and very probably both so we're
not convinced by this and President
Putin needs a actually to just clear off
because nobody thinks that what he is
saying is true he's killed repeatedly he
kills traitors he come to Britain to
kill people he thinks are traitors
Anthony can I ask you a question and and
Sergey your response in a tick as well
please um if we talk about Putin's
mindset and we imagine that when
pagosian uh stood up against him and
started that march to Moscow that really
was the first time in 24 years that
there had been descent what would
Putin's mindset be right now is it are
we looking at the beginning the slow
beginning of the end or does this
killing and let's labor The Killing
because undoubtedly it was does that
cement his his authority once again over
the Russian people firstly Anthony no
it's a sign of weakness yes he he may
Shore up his position in the short term
but nobody should be in any doubt at all
that things are going badly for Putin
he's not winning in Ukraine and he's got
to win in order to win the ukrainians
have simply not got to lose in order to
win he didn't dare go to Africa to speak
to the bricks there she delivered this
ridiculous talk to them saying that
Russia would lead the anti-colonialist
fight against the West if the African
leaders were stupid enough to believe
him I feel very sorry but there can be
no bigger colonialists in the world
today than Vladimir Putin he's in big
trouble he needed
and now he's had to kill him let me let
me bring Sergey back weaker Sergey won't
want to acknowledge this but let's say
that this is the beginning of the end of
Vladimir Putin what would happen next
Sergey what would happen to Russia what
would the Kremlin do what does this say
for Russian philosophy right now
because it will forget about that you're
going to put you another placement until
what against Russia cantino United
States Great Britain possibility to say
small Britain uh and another NATO
countries conducting hybrid War using
their Ukrainian proxy Army uh against
Russia when this war continue Russians
will not replace Vladimir Putin if it's
your war against Russia will continue 20
years Putin will keep his presidency
additionally uh 20 years excuse the
reported medicine is very good so he can
live until a 100 years but if your war
against Russia finished
put and I think we'll see one here and
then he will give the power not just
himself but whole generation of this uh
you know small uh uh uh baby boomers uh
will be replaced in Russia by two new
generation which main goal will be not
to protect Russia from uh aggression of
the United States and Britain but to
moderate nice country to develop Russia
and so on it means that your war is
giving to Paul uh to Putin the
dictionary yes and yes uh Duty uh to be
possible so okay um one final question
uh we know where your loyalties stand
and I understand that this is about both
sides of the argument I suspect even you
my friend would say to any uh you know
up and coming warlord not to go on a
private plane across Russia that would
be good advice Sergey Markov yeah
uh you know a Wagner group uh and pregos
advisory was a leader of my telegram
Channel sometimes even give me his
responses to some of my uh analysis and
uh play very important role in the
crisis period hello uh he give uh the
time to Russian army to build this
defensive online and now Russian army
as ever an absolute pleasure you blow my
mind I have to say Anthony Gleason thank
you very much indeed unbelievable now a
place where they will be watching these
events of the last few days and hours
extra closely as of course Ukraine which
ironically today is celebrating its
independence day and I'm Delight to be
joined Now by Ukraine MP Kiera radic
Kira how are you lovely to speak to you
again
hello Jeremy thank you so much for
having me and let me use this
opportunity to thank all of the people
of Great Britain for the fact that we
are celebrating our independence today
we are so happy to be alive and to be
fighting and thank you for standing with
us uh my pleasure our pleasure I'm gonna
pick up two things Sergey Markov said
the first was he called my country small
Britain try that again sunny and
there'll be trouble but Kira one thing
that happened is yesterday yesterday of
course brigosian's plane was shot down
the world knows that it was Vladimir
Putin he labeled pregosian a a traitor
it was 60 days ago uh Sergey Markov not
at all indoctrinated said he blamed
Ukrainian forces I'd love your response
to that tonight
well if we could have blown a plane do
you think it would be a precautions
plane
very good answer
um do you think that what pragoshin did
although it it ended with him in Exile
in Belarus and ultimately his death to
the Ukrainian people believe that this
is the beginning of the signs of
weakness uh in Putin and his government
you see what happened to precaution we
use as a very good argument to everybody
who says oh you have to talk to Russia
you have to strike a deal with Russia
because it's another additional proof
that they never keep their part of the
bargain they always lie and they are a
country that still operates by their
rule of power rule of force and not of
the rule of law and they have been known
of doing that in centuries and still
right now there are people who have
those illusions that you can have an
agreement with Vladimir Putin and he
will honor it no look what is happening
what happened to precaution and this is
exactly what we've been telling to
everyone hashtag I told you so it's very
interesting here just final question
um as we watch uh the events unfold and
the ludicrous comments remark often the
stuff that's coming out of Russia I
think most people will know the truth
but one of the debates one of the
phrases we have in England is better the
devil you know I I think a lot of people
would have looked at burgosian and
thought my God is it possible for
somebody to be worse than Putin do
ukrainians fear what would happen if
Vladimir Putin was taken out or removed
that actually the alternative could be
even worse for you and your people
the issue is that you will have to fight
any devil you meet any devil that wants
to destroy your country to kill whatever
you love you will have to fight whoever
would come and we are ready to fight any
kind of devil put in precaution whoever
else will be there okay listen
um happy happy uh Ukrainian Independence
Day from everybody in the United Kingdom
thank you so much for joining us on
censor we'll see you very very soon
right just after 8 30 and next oh God uh
the son of the original Snow White
director says that Walt Disney will be
turning in his grave and plans to update
the classic animation after the break
We'll be asking mirror mirror on the
wall is this the workiest film of them
all we're coming back in three
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think there's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservi party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's
the threat that you'd be worried about
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
been telling the trails you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored yes JK
standing in for the big dog as he
lounges in the sun we're working our
backsides off now let's move on the
backlash against the so-called woke Snow
White remake continues to grow as the
son of the original film's director says
his dad and Walt Disney would be turning
in their graves at the proposed changes
and for those not following this Saga
let me fill you in firstly you sitting
comfortably then I'll begin
all of this comes as Disney reported 900
million dollars worth of losses in
August alone after a series of woke
releases tanked at the box office so my
question tonight is should the new Snow
White be put to sleep and scrapped or
can it still have a happy ever after I
cannot wait for this segment joining me
now is journalist and author of the case
for Council culture you try saying that
Ernest Owens and the author in Babylon B
contributed to Ashley Saint Claire uh
good evening one and all um Ernest
you're a massive massive Disney fan
um do you think Uncle Walt would be
spinning in his grave at this uh well I
don't know how you describe it this um
remake of a classic
absolutely not I think that one of the
things that Disney did well with his
films was that he remade his own
versions of films of classic Disney
films I mean really fairy tales that
made a more Americanized for the
audiences and I think that this is just
in the Disney tradition
um and I always tell people that don't
like this version or they they're
suspicion anymore like it listen you can
go to Disney plus and you can watch the
1939 version Snow White and the comfort
of your own bedroom into your eyes bleed
but for some of us like myself I look
forward to seeing this new reimagining
of sunlight and I think so many people
need to just give it a shot
um can I just say Ashley I like I'm
probably you know a bit old-fashioned
I'm nearly 60. even older than peers um
I just find it suddenly Prince
Charming's a stalker suddenly
Everything's changed and and whilst
whilst I understand that the world has
changed you know my daughters and my
kids tell me I'm I'm an old bugger and
whatever but isn't isn't sad that
everything
everything seriously actually is going
to be scrapped this is just symptomatic
of a world is it not that says that
anything classic is rubbish and we
should modernize everything
they're hijacking our childhoods I'm not
sure why they're even calling it Snow
White at this point you're going to have
no love story you're changing the Seven
Dwarfs to seven diverse magical beings I
think it's an absolute atrocity to
hijack our childhoods in a place for
this this facade of progress and as you
know Disney's doing this just to be
quote unquote Progressive when they're
the least Progressive company out there
it's all a facade as you know they were
cowing and loudly and obnoxiously
complaining about Florida's don't say
gay Bill while simultaneously cutting
scenes about a man going on a date with
another man for the release of Avengers
end game in Russia
um I have to tell I've got a great clip
uh Piers Morgan interviewed um Dylan one
of the dwarfs have a watch
behind the scenes pictures from Disney's
live-action remaker Snow White release
this weekend there appears to be a
sizable problem where are the dwarfs
these are rules made for actors of my
stature I can't go out for the Harrison
Ford or the George Clooney rules because
that's not for me right and now it's
taken away
it I don't feel that's right
Ernest come on answer that the poor
man's not gonna get a job now man
because they've gone so woke
well I think that the reality of
diversity in film is that that actor
should actually be able to have other
roles that is not for the Seven Dwarfs I
mean you look at you know Game of
Thrones you look at some of these other
yeah but he's not going to play Tom
Cruise in me you know he's not going to
be in Top Gun is he and he's saying that
in the role I want it but but why not
you know I think that there was a time
where people that look like me couldn't
even be superheroes and we saw the world
evolve around that so I think that what
we need to stop doing is reinforcing
stereotypes about the limitations of
what Disney films can be what diversity
can look like in cinema and just get
with it because at one point you're
wondering why where are the roles of
people like him but then you're not
considering where are the roles for
people of color to be in films like Snow
White you're saying saying Miss Sinclair
that oh your childhood is being hijacked
no it's not you can go do Disney plus
and be nostalgic and watch all of those
old films if you want to but some of us
want to be in the current area my point
here's my point and I was only here for
one night only I'm allowed to give it I
say this to my daughters the whole time
Ernest and you and I gonna have this out
and Ashley can smile I absolutely accept
I absolutely accept that you have
different opinions and you want to
change things but what I will never
accept is that your generation want to
trash everything that's classic and
everything that I believed it no no let
me have my say from my childhood
everything is trash everything is
non-diverse and it's wrong why can't we
both live in the same world
because part of your role was
problematic called Pro vandalism can I
say can I say to you I didn't have
rights I have rights too but I agree
with you what was problem what was
problematic about snow white though
Ernest and what they do when they
pretend that this is all for female
progress and whatever and what they do
is they actually end up erasing women we
saw this with the remake of Mulan right
the original Mulan had a powerful story
arc she persevered through willpower and
strength and in the remake she's just
giving superpowers
can I jump in ladies and gentlemen can I
just say something by the way Ernest and
you need to know this apparently Prince
Charming right uh is is a demonstration
of True Love on the one hand or he's a
creepy stalker if he hadn't kissed her
she'd still be dead Earnest Snow White
wouldn't be alive
it's time to reimagine what consent
looks like in films in 2023 period
period just write a number
you have to remake Snow White
because that's fun let's be artistically
creative and here's the thing it's gonna
google
without taking a story
it's going to be great at the box office
well you're going to look at this glass
you're giving all this great program
it's not gonna be great at the box
office in all
box office flops with their woke films
like light year and the Little Mermaid
this is going to be a flop too and the
numbers are showing it and it's all a
facade of progress I mean that's an
interesting point Ernest Disney's losing
billions with this woke agenda
I don't think so I think
right here
hold on let's be declare it's not a walk
agenda I can tell you why light year did
not do well because I think in America
we're over I think a lot of that Toy
Story remakes that's why I think light
year didn't do well you want to talk
about blue Market I think the Little
Mermaid did okay I think it did modestly
well in my opinion but you have to
acknowledge that there were people who
had a different agenda against Ariel
being a black character and that racism
was undeniable and that's what drove it
I don't think racism is going to play a
role with Snow White as much and I think
it's going to be successful but I think
this has been the highlights Barbie was
too woke and now it's the highest
grossing film for Warner Brothers Studio
so the far right keep pushing their
agenda all they want but the numbers
show that people are interested in
seeing diverse characters there will be
hits there will be misses but that
doesn't mean that there's not a chance
if I could if I could if I could sum up
I I you know my role is to listen to
both sides nothing wrong with diversity
completely agree with you Earnest but I
also agree with Ashley when she says we
shouldn't destroy cancel obliterate and
slag off everything that has come from
before we will agree to disagree thank
you both very much and next on
uncensored really The Tick-Tock egg
cracking challenge really where parents
crack open eggs on their heads of their
kids is dividing opinion some say it's
unnecessarily mean the rest of us think
it's bloody hilarious we'll talk about
that after the break we're coming right
back
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk a divided America
watches on as Donald Trump prepares to
surrender in dramatic fashion to
authorities in Georgia over racketeering
and conspiracy charges the NHS brought
to a standstill with routine care
severely disruptive as senior doctors
walk out in a bitter row over pay and an
unlikely Alliance sees pretty Patel back
prince Andrew in his ongoing battle for
armed security that's all coming up at
nine
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored it's the last
part of a long evening I'm joined now by
the pat that's what they call him a
political journalist I love her Ava
Santina and talk TV presenter Richard
sice we're back together but you don't
love me I mean it's you know I don't
love you he will he said what he said
all right he's lovely to have you back
listen can we start we've got so much to
talk about and I'm gonna go right at it
and April 13 is going to start to me
India yesterday celebrating Landing a
rocket on the moon something like that
and yet we send billions of pounds
millions of pounds of International
Development Aid why don't they use their
own bloody money rather than ours
serious question I just think it's an
overly simplistic way to look at the
argument well give me another simple
okay well okay for the last what decades
there have always been millionaires
there have always been billionaires in
certain countries but it doesn't mean
that those billionaires and millionaires
are willing to share their wealth and
therefore if there is an opening and you
need to provide Aid to people then
that's our duty as humanitarians to do
so yeah but the mission costs 70 five
million dollars Richard Tyson we sent
billions of pounds of our money to India
they're an important Commonwealth
country but it's for them to make their
decisions if they can afford to have a
space program in which they've actually
had for decades then they should say
look actually we don't need your money
we're making these decisions and we're
deciding to send equipment to space
rather than to try and improve the life
of the billion plus people in India the
whole thing's absurd but it's our
stupidity They're laughing at our
ridiculous foreign aid program run by
our clueless civil servants the whole
thing's absolutely
expensive said on Jeremy Carr live
earlier this is a complete con this is
to get a trade deal with India and and
he's completely wrong on that this is
just our woke virtue signaling Civil
Service wasting our cash The Blob The
Blob and that's what I move on prince
Andrew uh idiot sorry my opinion uh he
he thinks this deranged human being who
can't get anything right that it would
be a good idea to try and get his state
funded security about three million
pounds a year pretty Patel the one that
they'll say apparently has been
supporting well she backtracked today
this is ludicrous he will never get back
yeah there's some kind of weird
subservience about that pretty Patel
response look I don't think that they're
stupid yeah it is stupid and I don't
really think that the monarchy should be
seen as anything other than celebrities
especially ones that have been disgraced
and have been now removed you know had
their titles removed I just look there
are a lot of people out there who were
Infamous in our potential under attack
by the public look I get death threats
every day apparently prince Andrew gets
them as well should I get a three
million pound security bonus I mean from
Paid full by the taxpayer that would be
ridiculous but you know it's good we
agree on this one I mean the whole
thing's absurd absolutely what on Earth
pretty Patrol thought she was doing you
know supporting prince Andrew just I
don't understand I mean that that
criticism of him is this entitled you
know human being who doesn't understand
anything just that just smacks of this
listen mate you did what you did go and
live somewhere are in Scotland with a
few quid from your brother and be quiet
because you're not coming back nobody
respects any part of what he's done and
that's understandable right it's kind of
giving Violet beauregarden you know
Willy Wonka and the chocolate when she
was like you know Please Mum can I have
something small it's like that okay
which was a very demanding child and
that's what he's giving me and you were
a demanding child no never I took I took
what I was given no that's not what your
mother said now before we get to the egg
Tick Tock challenge I want to ask you
all something
um peers I'm I'm so you know I've been
working all day right there's a tweet
from peers where is this tweet
uh is it is it oh yes he did a
photograph himself driving probably his
own yacht somewhere in the Caribbean and
he said and I quote Clooney or compo
from Last of the Summer Wine this is
because the goat says here has grown a
beard slightly white in my opinion
um so Clooney or compo from the the the
the summer one what would you think I
don't think I've ever like oh
God okay that's quite
I'm afraid to say he looks terrible and
as you say very white very age you see
the interesting thing is you lot work
with him I have no I don't care if I
mean he looks like compo no guys also oh
here we go this is two men here the
other man is on a yacht a rule getting a
bit upset about it is that what it is
wearing a couple of silver boxes
you are how old are you Tyson I'm the
same age as you but this is genuine no
it's not it is and it's just died as
anything absolutely no do you like older
memes
I'm just saying he's a silver fox thing
no yeah I mean I have been I've been
known to be a fan of that yeah there you
are you see I knew that because I know
well do you know what the latest Tick
Tock egg cracking challenge is all about
this is awful Isn't it what's going on
here full no but only because the
children are so young just just just
have a look at this because it's
extraordinary so so basically
um parents cracking eggs on their
toddler's heads uh Dr Megan Martin a
pediatric emergency medical consultant a
John Hopkins All Children's Hospital in
Florida revealed in a tick tock I'm not
a big fan of this it's not something
that benefits kids in any way I find it
in no way entertaining it's a disgrace
what do you think yeah I just think it's
sad that like these kids are spending
time with mum and dad and then their
reactions to smack them in well guess
what
I thought who's the kid well it's you
you see we know look because I look
younger there is a young man who has
worked tirelessly for me for the past
year he's called Luke he's our youngest
member of Staff Loki come here
and I want to be on television more than
anything are you sure you're all right
with this now do I do it on his air or
his forehead
oh
[Music]
you could tell Jeremy doesn't cook am I
doing it oh dear God
um
did that hurt no do you feel proud yes
can you imagine you imagine when you're
a kid saying Jeremy Carl smacked an egg
this is real journalism you know when
when you get older look at this forget
what they say go to college and learn
how to be a television because Jeremy
Kyle smashed an egg image shops give
Luke a round of applause
fantastic you clearly don't do much
cooking Jeremy what you know they're
nervous there's clearly
ties with respect to my friend cooking
that's not something you're known for is
it I'm a great hunter-gatherer I'm
brilliant at breakfast those are my
specialties yeah after you forage those
eggs earlier didn't you I saw you at the
back of the building earlier foraging
for them uh no they were from the spa
six British large eggs but well done to
Luke I think fantastic I've only got
about a minute left just very very very
quickly we were talking about I can't
say his name the guy very quickly 20
seconds is this the beginning of the end
of Putin does it show weakness do you
think to finish uncensored tonight I'm
not actually sure that he's dead I think
yeah I I'm I think just watch this space
but yeah look Putin is is uh hopefully
he's on borrowed time because he's he's
he's losing he's losing his his control
and everybody's looking and saying
it's an interesting one isn't it yeah
well I mean progression also famously
hates the west and he hates you know
he's very traditional really can't stand
us and I think if we get on board with
him then we're going to be the ones with
egg on our face
you see what she did there I think the
other thing is is that you wonder what
the alternative would be I mean Putin is
a frightening human but listen um I'm
sorry I was I was put up to that by the
way but Luke was very happy to do that
you can have the other five eggs I
actually don't eat eggs I'm so sorry why
not I'm sorry I do yeah well give him to
Richard Ty see what he could do with
them doesn't she make a good breakfast
Jeremy he just said he makes a good
breakfast listen thank you very much to
do the X and Ava Santina thank you
Richard Tyson thank you for putting up
with me that's all I have time for
uncensored tonight stand by for the talk
uh Daisy leading that'll be fantastic
talking about all the news and don't
forget Donald Trump in Fulton County
Jail Atlanta on talk about half past
midnight have yourselves a great
Thursday we'll see you Monday from Seven
Sarah
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]